we have new m1x leaks and updates so do
you guys want
the good news or the bad news first
because
fortunately or unfortunately we have
both so today we're gonna catch you guys
up
give you guys some updates and talk
about not only m
x macbooks but also imacs mac minis
and macbook air and a new display as
well
let's start out with something that at
this point is basically confirming
what we kind of know and that is the new
m1x macbook pros that we're all waiting
for the new 14-inch models
being out this fall as you guys know a
lot of us were expecting them
at wwdc in fact the chips that are going
in there for the m1x
that was actually leaked before the m1
chips with the higher core counts in the
m1x
so everybody was expecting that but
unfortunately we had
delays and then the next a logical step
was in the
summer time where we often had macbooks
being released before students hit
college but unfortunately because of the
situation
and supply shortages this is getting
pushed back to the fall
and mark german who has the best track
record
has now confirmed previous leaks within
the last few weeks
that the new macbook pros are launching
in november
at the latest so that is great we know
we will not have to wait into
2022 and his specific uh
headline was that they're coming
sometime between september to november
obviously we know that september is
iphone season november is when apple
added a new event last year for apple
silicon so that makes logical sense
of course it could come earlier with the
ipad kind of press releases usually
coming in october but i think november
makes a whole
lot of sense so finally after months and
months of waiting and some potential
delays
this machine will come out now at that
same event we are expecting
another m1x mac and that is the new
redesigned mac mini john proster has
seen it from multiple sources and he had
a 3d render created showing off this new
slim more updated futuristic design it
kind of matches up with the m1i max
where you have that top that looks
really clean possibly multiple colors
and of course with that m1x
it's going to fix multiple issues such
as only having two thunderbolt ports
on the current m1 mac mini and
having more display outputs as well with
that it is using that new magsafe
connector which is
really cool kind of unnecessary for this
but it's cool to see apple putting that
into their machines after having it be
gone for so long
so that is another m1x mac that will be
coming out
this fall and with that we have another
new
leak this time from nine to five mac
it's an exclusive that apple is testing
a new external display with a dedicated
a13 chip
and a neural engine built into it
now this is looking like it could be an
update to the pro display xdr that came
out just a couple
years ago but there is also the
potential that it could be a new lower
end display
that we have also had leaks and rumors
about for a while now because
let's face it a 5 000 display a plus a
stand that's a thousand bucks
is not accessible to most people and the
display
is very high-end and apple usually
doesn't have display updates
that often typically stick around for
five six seven or even eight years
so this actually makes a whole ton of
sense because if you guys remember
a while back we had rumors that apple is
making a display
with the built-in gpu so it's almost
like an external
gpu unit but built-in display so you
walk in you plug in your macbook pro
or maybe a mac mini and you get extra
performance now
with these new apple silk and macs it
doesn't make sense that that would
happen because they don't support
external gpus but if it is an
apple dedicated chip that's built in
that will give us
numerous benefits with the latest m1 max
and mac os
we have new exclusive features that are
not supported for
intel max you do need the apple silicon
built in
so if we have that chip set here that
could allow
some of these new features to be used
even with older macbooks it'll be a
selling point
to buy apple's new display now along
with that what people have done for a
while with their macbooks
is using egpu not necessarily for the
extra graphics power but to take the
load off of their internal graphics card
to keep the temperatures down and to
give great performance with different
monitors that are external so this would
also be a benefit taking the load off of
your
macbook or you know anything else and
give you
more performance for the task that
you're actually doing
there's also a chance that this can help
m1 max that only support one external
display
be able to add on multiples or even
daisy chain them
because you'll have that extra built-in
gpu to do that processing
just like some people are doing with
external display
adapters for their current m1 max and
getting i think up to six displays to
run
with that there's also the potential
that apple could put face id
into this display now of course that is
extra cost
but if they're already gonna have a
webcam built into it
and they're gonna have speakers built
into it why not add a few extra sensors
to allow face id to work
and as we've seen there leaks that apple
is working on this
in code that was in mac os big sur so it
is coming at least to
some max and if they do that they would
need a processor to be built in to have
that running properly and work
regardless of
which system that you connected to but
if they put this together and add this
feature it would be absolutely
amazing and now before we get into the
new macbook air redesign let's go ahead
and touch on
the last m1x mac and that is the 30
inch imac unfortunately we have a new
leak
from dillon dtk that says the high-end
imac
will be released in 2022
he also has a little bit more info but
first if you guys don't know about
dillon dkt he has a good overall
accuracy
apple track basically says that he's a
mysterious twitter account
with a remarkably accurate track record
for mac and apple's silicon
details so basically what he's saying
with these new 30-inch imacs which we
personally are really waiting for to
replace
our other machines is the fact that
apple just has too much products coming
out
obviously we've had supply and chain
issues because of this multiple things
have had to get pushed back
and apple doesn't want these machines
all releasing at the same time and
competing
with one another so unfortunately even
though that sucks for us and i know a
lot of you guys are waiting for those
machines
it makes a lot of sense for apple and
with that that also means that there's a
really good chance
that they could include face id into
these more expensive larger imacs
because that was rumored for 2022
so if that means that we had to wait
longer but get that awesome feature and
some other updates
i guess we will just have to wait for
that and it might be a benefit overall
and we expected to have better ports an
sd card reader faster 10 gigabit
ethernet
and a lot more performance so it's going
to be an awesome system
so we have to wait but i think it will
be worth it now the last thing that i
want to cover
are updates to the macbook air the new
redesigned version
uh and we have actually more info now
when it's gonna come out
it's exactly like we told you guys a
while back
what we expect based on apple's timeline
this one should include the new updated
m2 chip with extra performance less
limitations
and we have info about the mini led
display being included in there which is
crazy because the macbook air
is a lower end lower price point product
but what this is telling us
is pretty much exactly like we told you
guys and we were expecting
is that this will not just replace the
base model that comes in at 999
right now that we recommend to everybody
if apple is redesigning it
they're making changes they are adding
in this new display we expect it to stay
at the more expensive price
possibly 1200 dollars maybe 1300
it might even replace the base 13-inch
macbook pro
and then the redesigned 14-inch will be
at the higher price point
so this will be a nice model thinner
smaller we have renders of it
and then apple will keep the current m1
at the base level which is great for
so many people so what do you guys think
are you guys excited for these new
machines that are pretty much confirmed
now
with mark german for this fall in just a
few months
and what are your thoughts on the m1x 30
inch imax
no longer coming out in the fall but
having it to wait till most likely
springtime in 2022
to be able to buy that let me know down
below
thank you guys for watching this update
click that circle above to subscribe
check out one of those great videos
right over there this been max and i'll
see you in the next video
[Music]